[Music]
we're thinking about legs recently men
placed the hairy the lightly the sun's
out here in Berlin it's getting warmer
and more and more men seem to be partial
to short let me show you what I mean a
word of warning though sensitive viewers
might find the following pictures
upsetting even in my own Department
VW business you see
short can be very comfy and airy and
look quite sporty when you're on holiday
but in professional circumstances in the
office on the job not allowed for Borden
and no not even for you guys in the IT
department I'm sorry let me show you why
bond and corporate assets 2-0 60 billion
euros a month since the start of that
program in October 2014 it's been more
than 1.8 trillion euros money have you
actually listened to what I was saying
are you taking me seriously see what I
mean there are exceptions but that is
crazy
hey he's from the sports department
completely different set of rules there
and B he's crazy he can pull it off but
you and I are most definitely not crazy
no so if you want to avoid clothes that
make you sweaty and summer go for some
light wool or linen for example do that
you can stay cool and still show your
mean business so the long and short of
it go short on short
[Music]
you